[Musique]
je m'appelle rodrigo rosales je suis
colombien j'ai le kg de shit
comment ça va permettre de mentir tout
le temps tout le monde moi en axe
j'adhère à quoi tient le choc
vous savez que je peux vous faire vous
le promets
ma mère est morte effectué ma main je
pense qu'il aurait muté à l'umons une
dernière fois
chez votre nouvelle voisine de palier je
suis auxiliaire de vie je m'occupe de
gens comme vous jour 2 mois
oui mais parfois barbieux dimanche ses
amis passent à l'acte comme jésus relève
je marcherai voilà c'est juste un oui le
prestigieux qu'est ce qu'on raconte
et moi je suis la grande soeur voilà
voilà
florence vasseur célibataire vous devez
avoir un mille trucs à vous dire entre
entre parisiens ont su où je fasse ça et
je vous dise c'est bidon je suis pas
handicapé c'est pour draguer ta soeur
[Musique]
handicapée physique
bonjour bonjour
je peux vous parler weeks quinta dis
donc vous venez non je ne peux pas
bouger
comment la bande son serrières mal et
comment elle est intéressante elle est
belle il ya quelque chose je tiens à
florence vous êtes assis sur ma chaise
oui je sais pas bien ce que vous faites
juste sa façon je pense que les pas du
pain tue pas les pieds quand on s'en
sert pas
quand tout vous dire
c'est quoi c'est pour votre quartier
dans la nuit mais c'est mon mari
[Musique]